And the other field that will be good to transform for all of our data,
is the attendance field, which is stored as a string.
In this case, we transform the attendance field and
then overwrite the value on that same JavaScript object, in this case D.
And then we return D, which gets passed into the function.
So the way to think of this, to go from our initial data file
world_cup_geo.tsv to our draw callback function, which actually draws our chart.
The .tsv function of D3 reads in a row of world_cup_geo.
In this case let's say the date is a string 27-05-1934,
space 1600 hours and the string, 25,000 for the attendance.
It then gets passed to the transformation function.
In this case, an anonymous function that doesn't have a name.
We perform some transformation on that row or
JavaScript object that gets passed to it.
We transform the string that represents the date
using D3's date parsing into a JavaScript date object.
And also transform the string of
the attendance into an integer representation of the attendance.
And then past this new object to the draw fallback.